hello my name is matthias from datatab
and in this video i'd like to show you
how you can easily
create a frequency table online with
datatab
but first of all what is a frequency
table a frequency table
are created in statistics if you want to
display
the absolute and the relative
frequencies
of the characteristics of your variables
a frequency table
thus provides you with a table that
shows you how
often each value occurred in your data
a frequency table for the variable
gender for example
shows you how often the male and female
values
occur in your sample so let's have a
look at this
simple example you ask nine people what
their favorite
candy is two of them answer cake
four of them answer ice and three of
them
answer donut so then this will be your
frequency table
cake you have the frequency 2 eyes say
frequency 4
and donut the frequency 3 and
in total you have 9 people ask
so and here at the right side you can
see the
percentage so cake has 22 percent
ice 44 percent and doughnut
33 so now let's create
a frequency table by our own with data
tab first of all
if you want to use your own data you
must click on clear
table afterwards you can copy your own
data
into this table so i select this data
and copy them into the table so
in this example you simply ask 12
students
what is their favorite car print in
order to create a frequency table
you need to click on the tab descriptive
and now
you want to create a frequency table for
the variable
car brand so you simply click on the
variable
car brand further you want to calculate
the frequencies
and you can simply click on frequencies
now you will see here it's left
the frequency table for the car brand
further you can click on
percent and valid percent now you can
see here
the frequencies of the car brands
there's one
invalid value here we don't have any
value
so we have one invalid value and
here you can see the percentage of the
carbons
and the valid percentage of the carb
brands
if you liked this video please subscribe
to our youtube channel
if you have questions or feedback just
leave us a comment
thanks and bye matthias